THEY HAVE WON NINE IN A ROW.
BIG OVERER
SEE IF THEY CAN STAY CLOSE TO
THE PACK.
WE WENT OFF TO A GOOD START
HERE AT HOME.
MORGAN FROST BEHIND.
IN FRONT.
BRASSARD  IN
THE GAME.
MORGAN FROST WILL GET AN
ELEVATED ROLE HERE WITH THE
INJURIES TO SEAN COUTURIER
FREE.
AND BOARDS.
CROSBY WILL KEEP DISPLAY ALIVE.
HE GOES BACK TO THE SEEM TO
LETANG.
LETANG FREHIS WIFE.
HEINEN ON THE NET.
HE HAS TWO QUICK ONES IN THE
FIRST AND IT'S  Ray: THEY WANT
THAT.
>> John: WHAT A PLAY BY LETANG
POST ATHE CALL.
A  MIDDLE OF
WHAT DO THE FLYERS DO?
HERE THEY COME.
TURNOVER.
HAYES.
IN FRONT.
ANOTHER SAFE.
BUT LOOSESAVED BY HART.
SHOT JUST WIDE. SBAR.
SHOT RIGHT LETANG.
SAVED.
ORED
EARLIER TO MAKE IT 3-1. RUST, T
SAVE BY HART.  RODRIGUES CONTIN
OF THE BLUE LINE. FLYERS' DEFENS
HELLO DADDY.
SHORTHANDEDE
THIS WEEK.
GOOD JOB, LAUREN.
BRYAN BOYLE HAS PORTANT TO HIM.
AFTER THE SUMMER HE HAD WITH MO
AS HE DRAGS IT AROUND  BEATLES
STICK.
STICKS IT UP OVER THE GLOVE OF
GOAL OF THE YEAR.
SOMEHOW JARRY SAVE.
>>